su paso por el número 10 de Downey
Street es oficialmente el más fugas en
la historia del país
tras seis semanas como primera ministra
de Reino Unido la conservadora Liz se
dio ante la presión de su propio partido
[Aplausos]
Reconozco que da la situación no puedo
cumplir con el mandato por el que fue
elegida por el partido conservador he
hablado con Su Majestad del Rey para
notificarle que dimito como líder del
partido
tras fue designada como primera ministra
por los miembros del partido conservador
tras la salida de Boris Johnson golpeado
por el denominado parygate pero el
respaldo que le fue otorgado se vino en
picada tras presentar un programa
económico que hizo temblar a los
mercados y precipitó de la caída de la
libra esterlina en medio de la crisis
despidió a su ministro de finanzas cuasi
cuarteme y este miércoles renunció la
ministra del interior ante la cámara de
los comunes dijo ser una luchadora y no
alguien que renuncia pero ese intento de
mostrar poder no le Fue suficiente el
comité de 1922 un subgrupo encargado de
los asuntos internos del partido le dio
la espalda atrás al ver que la mitad de
los Stories había perdido la confianza y
a pesar de que las normas dicen que no
pueden impugnar a ningún mandatario
antes de un año
he hablado con el presidente del partido
Jake Berry
me ha confirmado que será posible llevar
a cabo una votación y concluir una
elección de Liderazgo para el Viernes 28
de octubre
el opositor partido de laborista
aprovechando su favorabilidad en las
encuestas Busca que haya nuevas
elecciones
el riesgo en este momento es continuar
con este caos no tener un gobierno
laborista estable por eso debe haber
elecciones generales
deja un partido dividido sin un líder
que unifique a las diferentes facciones